rescue operations now at the end of the
third day
dozens of bodies have been recovered but
more than 160
are still missing several feet of debris
and slush
have been removed as part of this
24-hour operation
involving the army and specialist rescue
teams
and at the forefront of everyone's mind
is time
as the hours pass the slimmer the
chances of survival
this is the tunnel which is on priority
for the rescue as they believe there may
be
35-39 people still trapped out here even
after 48 hours
of this tragedy there has been no
contact with the workers since sunday
when the nanda devi glacier burst
through the dam here
and sent a torrent of icy waters into
the valley below
but nothing is established so far
because we could not contact with them
that nothing has been established
where they are actually we are hoping as
per the
technology and the psychology of a
person once the crisis comes how he
reacts
on the basis of that the progress is
as more rescuers arrive sniffer dogs
await their turn
once a bath has been cleared
up above choppers scan the area
on the other side of the tunnel an army
mountaineering team
rattle down checking for possible life
and openings in the tunnel in the
darkness
drones are used to ensure it's safe for
rescuers to proceed
for the last 48 hours my boys are
involved all of us are involved
we wanted to save as many lives as we
can and in the bargain if you are able
to recover the dead bodies
it will be good for us
but for the families gathering here
their hope is for more than a recovery
operation
my only brother younger brother we've
been waiting for him for three days now
we are praying that he returns safely
he's got two small daughters and our
mother at home
we have no father he's all that we have
the search could last for several days
for now
all they can do is wait neville lazarus
sky news at papua 1 uttarakhand